so wait so you've been known to do some
karaoke and i heard that like one of
your favorite famous people that you go
to is also mine you love doing eminem i
do well i do too um
i feel like people expect me to sing so
i rap and i love him i also like i i
feel like if you were if you came of age
at a certain time like we were a bunch
of the you know the the whitest middle
class kids in england being like i need
to internalize all the lyrics to real
shady like it was uh yes i i know that's
i'm always like amazed how well i know
some songs when i go to do the karaoke
because oh this is like in there but
it's like when we were in like junior
high i feel like that's the time we
memorized everything like those are the
songs i know by heart i feel like yeah a
lot of it's very like the music that
means the most you when you're a
teenager you're coming of age yeah yeah
okay that later yeah i know i agree i
agree and it was good music um so you
often carry with your girlfriend y'all
been together is it ten years uh you'll
be ten years this year that's amazing
it's aaron right oh my gosh
that's that's amazing 10 years so do you
all karaoke together do you want to do
okay she goes forward too because also
like in real sense lady there's a very
long chorus where there are a lot of
times you have to say will there be
something
so she does a lot of that she's like
very good at she's a high girl yeah yeah
yeah and also we have done uh we do a
lot of like uh we've done some duets
like greece no we didn't you should lean
in um there's this what i always forget
the name of it it's all coming back to
me now oh my god celine linda yeah yeah
we like go for that and that is again uh
that's one of the like that's a longer
song it's like seven minutes i feel like
they aren't the extended version and
there are some insane and great lyrics
in it yeah and some dramatic pauses yes
yeah long solos where you just have to
be up there yeah feeling it yeah maybe
some interpretive movement yeah i don't
and erin's a good dancer though yeah i
love it i want to see aaron carry
[Music]
you